IT'S NOT LIKE THEY NEEDED TO
PROVE HOW BRUTAL AND DEPRAVED
THEY ARE.
THE BEHEADINGS OF AT LEAST 20
HOSTAGES WERE CONVINCING ENOUGH.
BUT THIS DISTINCT CHANGE IN
EXECUTION TACTIC, THE BURNING
ALIVE OF JORDANIAN PILOT MU'ATH
AL KASEASBEH SEEMS TO TAKE ISIS
TO A NEW LEVEL.
>> THIS IS AN ESCALATION AND
IT'S DIFFERENT.
>> Reporter: ANALYSTS SAY IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
MINDS OF ITS LEADERS BUT THEY
OFFER SOME POSSIBLE REASONS FOR
THE HORRIFIC NATURE OF THIS
KILLING.
THERE COULD BE SYMBOLISM IN
BURNING THE CAPTURED PILOT.
BEFORE THAT MOMENT IN THE VIDEO,
IMAGES OF DESTRUCTION, POSSIBLY
FROM COALITION BOMBINGS, ARE
SHOWN.
>> IT APPEARS THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO CREATE THIS PERVERSE
MORAL SYMMETRY BETWEEN THIS
PILOT AND THE COALITION DROPPING
BOMBS FROM THE SKY, DROPPING
FIRE FROM THE SKY, I'M SURE THEY
WOULD SAY, AND THEN HIS BEING
BURNED ALIVE IN TURN.
>> Reporter: EXPERTS SAY ISIS
MAY HAVE WANTED TO SHOW A
DIFFERENT KIND OF CRUELTY HERE
BECAUSE THIS WAS A COMBATANT
AGAINST THEM AS OPPOSED TO THE
AID WORKERS AND JOURNALISTS THEY
BEHEADED.
THEY MAY HAVE FELT THERE WAS
VALUE IN SHOWING OTHER POTENTIAL
ENEMIES THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU TAKE TO THE BATTLEFIELD
AGAINST US.
>> THIS IS A TACTIC THAT WORKED
BEFORE FOR ISIS IN IRAQ.
THEY PUT OUT A SERIES OF BRUTAL
VIDEOS LAST YEAR AND THAT DID
HAVE AN IMPACT ON IRAQI SOLDIERS
WHO TURNED AND FLED FROM MOSUL
WHEN ISIS ADVANCED ON THE TOWN
DESPITE THE FACT THE IRAQI ARMY
VASTLY OUTNUMBERED ISIS AT THE
TIME.
>> Reporter: UNLIKE PREVIOUS
VIDEOS, THIS ONE DOESN'T FEATURE
THE BRITISH ISIS EXECUTIONER
KNOWN AS JIHADI JOHN, POSSIBLY
BECAUSE IT'S GEARED TOWARD A
DIFFERENT AUDIENCE.
BUT THERE COULD BE A MUCH MORE
BLUNT, UNVARNISHED EXPLANATION
FOR THE BRUTALITY OF THIS
MURDER.
THAT THIS PARTICULAR GROUP OF
TERRORISTS JUST ENJOYS THE
CRUELTY.
>> THERE IS SOME ELEMENT WHEN
YOU WATCH THIS THAT IT'S JUST
SICKENING AND MAKES YOU THINK
THERE IS ALSO JUST A CRUELTY FOR
CRUELTY'S SAKE.
>> Reporter: WAS THIS PART OF
THE CRUELTY?
PEOPLE GATHERED IN ROQQA
WATCHING THE PILOT'S DEATH ON A
BIG SCREEN OUTSIDE.
IT'S NOT